[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH GORDON: Although
Voice Actions are already
available on many
different Android devices,
there's nowhere where they're
more important than in the car.
Already you can reply to
messages simply by speaking,
and now you can listen to
music and other audio content
simply by saying what
you want to hear.
Let's see, or rather
hear, an example
of how this works on our
reference application.
Listen to "Awakening" on
Universal Media Player.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Playing "Awakening"
on Universal Media Player.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH GORDON: How cool is that?
I'm Josh Gordon from
Google, and today I'll
show you how easy
it is to add Voice
Actions to your existing
Android auto applications.
This is important
to do, because it
will help users stay
focused on the road
as well as enjoy the ride.
Let's head back to the
studio and see how it's done.
Voice Actions can be used to
start and control playback.
Users initiate a Voice Action
by tapping the mic button
on the car's display
or by pressing
the corresponding
steering wheel control.
You don't say "OK Google" as
you would on a mobile device.
You can start playback in
a number of different ways,
but they all take the
form of Play Query on App.
Of course, you don't
need to say the app
name if it's already running.
If you'd like to hear music
of certain genre, you can say,
"play jazz on app," or you can
say, listen "listen to rock."
You can also request
to hear music
by artist, album, song, radio
station and even by playlist.
You should support all of these
that make sense for your app.
In addition to
starting playback,
Voice Actions can also
be used to control it.
When content is playing, users
can press the steering wheel
button and say commands like
"pause music" or "next song."
And here's something
great for you.
If your app isn't already
in the foreground when
a Voice Action comes
in, Android Auto
will launch it automatically.
This means that Voice
Actions give you
a way to take users directly
from the home screen
into your content.
Now let's see how to implement
Voice Actions in your existing
audio app.
First, if you'd like a refresher
on how to build an audio app,
check out this great
video by Wayne Piekarski.
The first step is to add the
Media Play from search entry
to your manifest.
This enables Auto to
launch your app in response
to "playback voice action."
Next, implement the On Play From
Search method inside your media
session callback.
When the user finishes
speaking, Auto
delivers the speech recognition
results to this method.
In your implementation,
you should
search your media library
for matching content,
build your media sessions audio
queue, and then start playback.
There are two parameters
to this method,
and to understand them,
let's say the user says,
"play Miles Davis" on your app.
The first parameter
contains the search query,
in this case the
string "Miles Davis."
The extras contain additional
information Google provides.
In this case Google detects
that Miles Davis is an artist
and adds an Artist
Extra to the bundle.
These are the different extras
provided by Android Auto,
and when they're
available you can
use them to do a structured
query of your database,
as opposed to having
to search all fields.
They won't always
be available though,
so you should also
implement Logic to search
based on just the query string.
Here's an example of how
you can retrieve the extras,
and you can find a
complete code example
in the link at the
end of this video.
Also be sure to check for
an empty query string.
This can happen when the user
doesn't specify any search
terms.
For example, if they just
say, "play anything."
Handle this case by playing what
makes most sense for your app.
For example, a recent
or favorite song.
Next, implement Search
Logic to find content
that matches the user's query.
If your search doesn't
return immediately,
set the playback state
to "state connecting,"
and perform your search
on an async thread.
Build your media sessions Audio
Queue with the search results,
keeping in mind there
could be more than one.
For example, if the user
searches for an album,
add all its songs to the
queue so the next song
starts playing automatically
after the current song
finishes.
And when search
results are ready,
be sure to start playback
without requiring the driver
to take any other action.
On the other hand, if no
search results were found,
stop playback and show an error.
Now it's time to enable
Playback Controls.
When the user says a
command, Android Auto
triggers the corresponding
method in your Media Session
Callback.
There are just two steps.
First, set these flags on
your Media Session Object.
Now you only have to implement
the corresponding callback
methods.
For complete code example of
how both types of Voice Actions
work, check out the Universal
Media Player Reference
app, and you can see
our developer training
for much more info.
Thanks very much for joining
me, and see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]